it's a death you haven't heard about
right in the middle of a neighborhood
good evening I'm Denise Valdez and I'm
Brian Loftus a father shot and killed in
front of neighbors his family demanding
answers eight news now investigator
David charn's asking questions about why
the public was never alerted David
Roderick Beasley's family contacted the
87 investigators asking why his death
was simply never publicized they allege
North Las Vegas city leaders not police
but higher leadership are trying to hide
crime there now this shooting happening
nearly two weeks ago near Tropical
Parkway in Pecos it wasn't until we
asked police about it that we learned
about the city's seventh homicide so far
this year
it's heartbreaking that my mom has to
walk out of her door every morning and
look down the street to know that her
son was killed there China Beasley says
someone shot and killed her brother not
far from the family home in this North
Las Vegas neighborhood 36 year old
Roderick Beasley Spud as his family and
friends call him died May 17th Chyna
says the coroner told her Roderick was
shot six times three in the back from my
understanding what all the Neighbors
when they came forward to talk to us
they said he wasn't bothering anybody at
all he was just standing in the middle
of the street just talking and singing
to herself and rapping he was in his own
little world but something happened
possibly with a neighbor leaving Beasley
with those gunshot wounds police never
put out a statement about the homicide
you look on the news and the other day
there's something going on in North Las
Vegas it's all over the news why is it
that you want people to know that this
happened I want answers I want answers
from my mom and my family and my nephew
Beasley says the lack of public
information means fewer possible leads
for police and more concern with a
potential suspect out of custody
spokesperson for the police department
says they are working on the case and
following up on All Leads we haven't got
any answers China feels her brother's
death simply isn't being acknowledged
not giving us no information you're
making people want to just it's right
down the street making people just want
to retaliate but we don't want that we
want peace and we want to lay our
Brethren at peace
North Las Vegas Police say it would be
premature to release any information on
that crime they say they have made no
arrests and there also appears to be two
other homicides in the city that
happened this past Sunday and Monday
that we didn't know about that would be
the ninth and 10th so far this year
we're working to get information on
those as well I'm David charns 8 news
now David thank you you can always help
police across the valley by submitting
an anonymous tip through Crime Stoppers
they offer rewards for information that
leads to convictions